hello I'm Dave Reuben this is the Ruben
report it is November 15th 2023 we're
live streaming on Rumble locals and
YouTube Share subscribe tap that
notification Bell if you have not and if
you want to join us for the postgame
show as always Ruben report. locals.com
and and that is also where if you'd like
to join us on our new live Callin show
which airs every day well except for
Friday Saturdays and Sundays so really
Mondays through Thursdays at 1 p.m
Eastern uh it's called people of the
internet because we talk to you and you
talk to us and we communicate and try to
figure some stuff out uh you can submit
questions and join us live at Ruben
report. locals.com the theme of the
program today is that we are getting
close to the poort point where if you do
not stand up for yourself and your
values and your family and your
community and your nation and your
heritage and all of that stuff you're
going to give it away we might be giving
it away already I think more of us are
starting to realize that we've uh kind
of let this slide a little bit too long
uh but it is time to push back and it's
time to push back by saying what you
think it's time to push back by going
against the corporations that would
gladly financially financially penalize
any of us for saying what we believe
it's time to push back against the
education institutions that are teaching
us all the wrong things and it's time to
push back against the politicians who
are the sort of hack panderers of the
day who are using all of the division uh
to just attain more and more power like
we are getting close to the precipice
folks and uh it's a time for choosing I
think I came up with that phrase just
just now uh before we get to all that
let me talk to you guys about gravity
def shoes and then I promise you we've
got a deep one today guys I want to tell
you about something that's been making
my days a whole lot easier gravity to
Fire Shoes these shoes are something
else I mean I'm a fan of comfortable
Footwear as you all know but these shoes
take it to a whole new level more than
just shoes they're basically clouds for
your feet I'm not kidding in a double
blind study by Olive View UCLA Medical
Center and published in the Journal of
the American podiatric Medical
Association participants experienced 85%
less knee pain it's the most powerful
shock absorption system put into a shoe
gravity to fire has this patented Verso
shock technology it's like a mini
trampoline in your shoes whether you're
strolling through the park running
errands or even just lounging at home
these shoes have got your back or I
should say your feet even better they're
stylish you get both comfort and style
that looks great and feels great so
here's the deal this gravity devire
offer is exclusive to the Reuben report
head over to
gy.com
gy.com use the promo code Ruben 20 at
checkout and get an extra $20 off your
order this $20 discount is a thank you
gift from Gravity to fire for you being
with us today why not your why not treat
your feet to some well-deserved Comfort
check out
gdefy docomo promo code Ruben 20 and
give your feet the love they
need to me I felt uh that was like an
evening read right there that's what you
got out of me this morning all right
let's talk about pushing back because we
know the barbarians are at the gate and
as I often quote my good friend Douglas
B one day The Barbarians will be at the
gate and we will debating we will be
debating what gender pronouns to call
them well they're there they're here
they're marching through our streets
they're calling for genocide uh we have
members of Congress who are siding with
the terrorist group we are watching
Western values be shredded in the cities
of the West and it's not just the kind
of foot soldiers that you see out on the
street it's also how corporations behave
related to anyone who pushes back ever
so slightly on any of the important
issues of the day so I want to start by
showing you two clips from Theo V's
podcast we've shown you a couple clips
of Theo Von over the years Theo's a
comedian and he had UFC president Dana
White on and they were talking about how
an Advertiser told Theo to take down his
podcast with RFK Jr I think you will see
how this will set us up the rest of the
program go when you do a sponsorship
deal with somebody you have to look deep
into who they are and you know who's
running the company who's making the
decisions and are you aligned yeah I
love that man yeah because we had Robert
Kennedy Jr on and we had a company call
or a couple companies call after that
and say yeah just stuff about them we're
not advertising on this episode my
advertisers like you guys need to take
the episode Down you know and uh and and
we ended up what's wrong with with him
nothing nothing guy's brilliant guy's a
smart him for seven years great guy I
mean a neat man right I I've never met
him yeah I've only watched his stuff and
and you got this whole Democrat
Republican all this crazy
he's a Democrat yeah
right but now they hate him just because
he doesn't believe like he's a Democrat
with common sense right yeah right he's
like an old school Democrat yeah and
smart guy whatever
let me tell you this let me tell you
this this is
America you can have whoever you want on
your podcast you can do whatever the you
want to do imagine a sponsor that
sponsoring you calling you and telling
you that you can't have this guy what
sponsor did it um was it I let me think
and I'm not afraid to name him I don't
know if I remember I really don't right
I don't know if I believe you but okay
that's fair um all right first off at
the end of today's show uh theovon
suddenly does remember what sponsor it
was you're GNA actually be quite shocked
because it's a fairly huge company so
we're going to play a clip at the end I
do want to give a shout out to Connor
who's been working overtime today uh
Connor's my director of course and I
told him before the show could we bleep
some of the F bombs there or could we I
well I said could we bleep all the F
bombs there were so many F bombs there
that he he could not bleep all of them
we lost control of the F bombs so he's
working hard you're still get your
guacamole with your Chipotle today I
appreciate it but yes we're going to
play some other clips that some more F
bombs are going to be thrown out there
and as you guys know I've been trying to
control them myself despite the state of
the world anyway to address what's going
on there specifically RFK Jr is
obviously not so radically outside of
anything that any sane person could
could call decent that you would not be
allowed to have a podcast with a
sponsorship just because he was the
guest right like we all know that I I
disagree with RFK on a bunch of stuff
his climate stuff he's for reparations
he was against the affirmative action
decision that the Supreme Court made and
I had him on the show and talked about
that stuff he invited me to do an event
with him if you haven't seen it it's on
our channels now in La a couple weeks
ago despite the fact that he knows that
I'm supporting Dan santis like the guy
is as freaking decent a Democrat as you
are going to get in 2023 but the reason
I wanted to start off with that clip is
what you are now seeing and and well you
guys have been seeing it for quite some
time and certainly if you do what I do
for a living you've been seeing it for
quite some time is that there are a
series of corporations that want to make
sure that if you talk to people who are
just a little bit different say in this
case with RFK it's mostly because he
left the Democratic party and he's been
so critical of them when it comes to
coid stuff they want to make sure that
nobody will talk to him because they
won't be able to make a dime doing it
right if every podcaster is like well
like okay I've got an interview show RFK
wow he's pulling it about 20% Which for
an independent pretty nuts he's going
after the Dems that's pretty good he's
an old school Democrat he's got Kennedy
in the last name like this is a guy I
should talk to but then if you look at
your numbers and you're like I'm running
a business and I have to hire a director
and a producer and a social media guy
and an editor and all that and oh I'm
not going to make a dime while doing it
which means you will lose money because
you still got to pay your people well
that is the type of corporate coercion
that actually tramples on speech and we
are seeing it repeatedly I do want to
note that Dana White and the UFC
obviously have a deal with Rumble and we
started locals and ultimately when we
merged with Rumble and the reason I do
this show in partnership with Rumble
right now is not only because I'm a part
owner but we built an ad system so every
time I read an ad for Gravity to fire as
I did today or whatever it might be we
know these guys aren't going to bail on
us so we actually are building that
alternate economy now I want to show you
one more clip from that uh show uh which
here is Dana now talking about how he's
gotten into crap when he's taken
pictures with Donald Trump but uh he
does not sit down and take crap he
stands up and pushes back imagine and
this happened to me too this this
happened to me I posted a video for
Trump right on my personal social media
and one of our big sponsors called and
said take that down you know what I said
go fck yourself yeah you vote for
whoever you want to vote for and I'll
vote for whoever I want to vote for
that's how this works I don't even care
who you're voting for it's none of mying
business you yeah don't ever call
me and tell who to vote for yeah yeah
yeah I think a lot of people feel in
fear these days you know a lot of people
feel in fear that if they don't vote for
certain people they're going to lose
their jobs I mean it's Hollywood for
example think about how crazy that is it
sounds insane it sounds just like well
it'll keep happening unless more people
stand up for themselves and give them
the you response I will never ever
answer to a Advertiser never yeah I've
been through it yeah believe me yeah
listen No I'm really easy solution pay
me what you owe me and you go your way
and I'll go mine pretty easy solution
that's it yeah yeah don't you can't ever
let these these people hold you hostage
or try to you know try to change who you
are or what you stand for or um try to
try to uh determine how you're going to
run your business
yeah
that starting to think that the button
doesn't really accomplish
anything how many times did you have to
Connor's finger is like this he's like
look at my hand from trying to bleep all
the fs as if you don't know what he's
saying anyway we're we're trying to keep
it somewhat familyfriendly but the point
is that that is the attitude with the F
bombs that is the attitude it is the
only way that we will ever get out of
this madness again whether you are
taking a video with Donald Trump or you
are doing an interview with RFK or what
whatever it might be within within the
basic parameters of what a free Society
can tolerate if corporations are going
to silence you for that we better start
building alternative things and oh yeah
well that's exactly what we're doing and
again why we're on Rumble and locals and
everything else so now I want to connect
this to sort of more widely what's been
happening in the mainstream media and
yesterday our show got bananas views
yesterday and a lot of people were
commenting that this this sort of middle
segment middle 15 minutes that we did
with all of the main media people who
have been given the notes once again
with they got a double down on calling
Trump a Nazi because we have people out
on the streets who are calling for the
genocide of the Jews and praising Hitler
and all that but they're on the
Palestinian side let's say of this thing
and they're not white supremacists so we
better ramp up the Donald Trump and his
supporters are white supremacists kind
of thing to freak them out because also
Trump is now polling uh quite well and
beating uh Joe Biden in five of the six
swing States and as you guys know
unfortunately the situation we're at in
America now is that really it's those
swing States kind of are the only ones
that matter right we know which way
Florida is going to vote we know which
way California is going to vote any who
misinformation specialist from the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC Rachel matow went on step col
Bear's quote unquote comedy show last
night and you're not going to believe
who she compared Trump too and did very
well against it um that is the hopeful
nature of this book which I want to get
into in just a moment but first I want
to ask you about what's been happening
recently on on Veterans Day on a
Veterans Day speech Trump called the
left Vermin and
fascists and you know a two or thing
about fascist in this book why do you
think he's leaning into to these
comparisons yeah I think it's important
that it very clearly wasn't an adlib
this wasn't something that uh he riffed
on it was seemed to have been in his
teleprompter Trump did that at the same
time that we've had these leaks kind of
official leaks from his campaign that he
wants to build camps for millions of
people um that he wants to professional
camps though professional looking I like
the no Crocs element just classes it up
a lot but camps for millions of people
and Americans he also wants to invoke
something called the Insurrection act
which will allow him to use US military
force against American civilians at home
and he says he's going to invoke that on
day one which would give him from that
day forward the ability to use the Army
against us at home um so doing floating
all of those things at once and calling
his opponents Vermin he's deliberately
inviting the criticism that he is
behaving like a Hitler or musolini style
fascist there's so much there so first
off you know just quickly on the word
vermin because maybe it is true I think
you could probably make some argument
that maybe someone who wants to be
president who was president shouldn't
call his opponents Vermin it's a little
different when say a pundit or a media
guy makes fun of the other half but I
maybe you could argue something around
that but I at the same time I can make
the counter argument which is you guys
run around calling him Hitler and all
the Republicans white supremacist all
the time so Vermin or white supremacist
like we could probably go either way on
that uh as far as using the military and
building camps and everything else it's
not against the Americans he's talking
about how to deal with the illegal
immigrants and the people that are here
who are at these rallies who are
radically anti-america and we've
completely lost control of uh again
either you have a country or you don't
but the the broader Point without even
getting into the minutia of all of that
is that they are ramping up the Trump is
Hitler thing they have people out on the
streets their base the MSNBC base the
Democrat base the ilhan Omar Hamas
caucus Rashida Talib crew they have
thousands of people in our streets
calling for the genocide of the Jews and
these clowns have the gall to say that
Donald Trump is the next Hitler it's
just completely insane but speaking of
completely insane there's another guy
that's on late night TV nobody really
cares about this guy nobody cares about
this guy does anyone watch this show I
we we've shown a couple clips of him I
suppose Seth Meers nobody's interested
in this but I guess he's just part of
the machine so you get a job okay you
don't really say anything 20 writers to
be that funny which is deeply deeply
depressing all I have is Connor and his
busted finger uh anyway uh here's Seth
Meers calling well racist and the
stuff this D racist stupid thinks he can
swoop in and set up a dictatorship in
2024 despite having like nine sets of
handcuffs on him first of all he's
surrounded by moranic criminal goons
like Rudy Giuliani and Steve Bannon who
can barely string a coherent sense
together without simultaneously
committing a crime here that's openly
fascist rhetoric and too many Americans
become numb to it because it's Trump and
he's a big sweaty who can barely
string three words together and
sometimes he dances on stage like a guy
in the locker room who's trying to towel
off his ball sack but Trump is very much
planning on completing his authoritarian
takeover if he wins in 2024 and it's
clear he's got the support of the
Republican party which has become a
movement fundamentally opposed to
democracy yes yes we're all very
impressed that you get your same lines
from the same people doing the other
late night shows who were all on the
same time as you and all the
corporations put out the same pools
whether it's Jimmy Kimmel or Steven coar
you that's fine so the other thing it's
Trump and Hitler right it's Hitler and
Nazis and all that the other one is
fascism and I want to talk about fascism
for a moment because fasc ism is the
Confluence of corporate power and
government power that's what fascists
like to do they like to combine these
things and step you know put the boot on
you the citizen now does that sound a
more like Donald Trump and Maga or does
it sound more like what the Democrats
have been doing say with ABC NBC CBS CNN
New York Times Washington Post uh
they're also putting the guy up on all
of these trumped up charart chares
Federal cases and state cases trying to
take away his New York City business
license it's like you you don't want the
guy to run for president so you have
these Federal cases and then you're also
in New York trying to take away his
business life so he can't license so he
can't even run hotels which one sounds
more like fascism what would a fascist
government do to people they don't like
it would make sure they couldn't work it
would make sure that they couldn't run
for office etc etc but the point is that
if they call Trump Hitler then they will
call you
a Nazi now once again we return to
MSNBC and Jen staki here she has Karen
Dunn talking about how it's uh White
supremacists at those pramas rallies I
did not know that I just want to start
with because I think when people hear
this they're like wait what why are
white supremacists showing up at these
Pro Palestinian rallies what do they
want out of this well overall Jen and
thanks for having me uh what they want
is they want an all-white ethnos state
in North America and as crazy as that
sounds that's actually an articulated
goal of the Neo-Nazi and white
supremacist movement in the US and one
of the things that helps them rally the
troops uh is anti-Semitism so now in the
US we're experiencing a massive uptick
in anti-Semitism incidents are up
something like 388 per and the white
supremacists Neo-Nazi groups see an
opportunity to advance some of the same
themes some of the same anti-Semitic
tropes that they've been plugging away
at for
years I don't know what she is talking
about I mean I understand that she's
making up a story that there are white
supremacists at the pramas rallies but
we've looked at a lot of the videos we
couldn't find any neo-nazis there uh if
you can find neo-nazis hanging out with
the brown Arab people screaming kill the
Jews generally generally speaking
neo-nazis let's say white supremacists
who want white people to reign Supreme
uh they don't hang out with a lot of
brown people who many of whom are
illegal in the country that would be
considered that yeah you know I was
doing the math earlier it's a little
confusing so there's literally no
evidence of that but you can see exactly
what they want the brainwashed
non-playable characters who watch MSNBC
to think oh my God it's not the brown
people who are screaming from The River
To The Sea and Hitler is great and kill
all the Jews it's not those guys are the
bad guys it's the white people who are
with them anyway here's a pramas rally
outside of Joe Biden's Delaware home try
to spot the white supremacist maybe we
should probably throw this in slow
motion but we we'll do regular speed and
see what
[Music]
happens fire now fire now we have you
have a good amount of yeah I mean we
just don't know where the white
supremacists are but again if you're a
white supremacist at a Hamas rally we
want to hear from you join us at Ruben
report. locals.com uh the thing that
these people do have in common
regardless of skin color is they're all
Democrats they are all Democrats and
when they chant from The River To The
Sea it is from the Jordan River to the
Mediterranean Sea and you're not going
to believe what's there the place where
the Jews live so they are calling for
genocide they know damn well what
they're doing uh when they go on TV and
pretend that they don't and it's call
for peace and coexistence and everything
else it's like well actually there's one
place in the Middle East that has some
level of coexistence and tolerance and
equality for Jews and Arabs and Muslims
and Christians and everything else it's
the place you're trying to wipe off the
map okay I know you guys got it uh so
let's go from Delaware to Dearborn
Michigan which is Ground Zero for the
Hamas movement in the United States of
course that's Rashida talib's district
and look what flags they put on the
official Dearborn height sign that is
government property that now have the
flags of Hamas and again you can say no
that's the Palestine flag Palestine is
not a state nor ever was a state who was
the Prime Minister who was the president
you get all that stuff okay fine um but
the idea that a putting aside whether
you think it's a Hamas flag or not right
uh the idea that a foreign entity's flag
is now hanging on state property in a
district run by Rashida Talib who
obviously is a Hamas supporter uh I
think this is a bit of a problem and
speaking of problems you know one of the
things I keep saying is it I think there
is a somewhat principled position not
not exactly principled but I think
there's there's a decent human position
to just be like you know I don't really
care about the Jews that much just not
going to get involved and I don't really
care about Israel that much I'm just not
going to get involved but the problem is
these people the people who were going
after the Jews and Israel they care
about you and they care about your
freedoms and it doesn't matter whether
you live in New York City dear in
Michigan in Brussels Paris London or
elsewhere because they are here for all
of your Western values and here is just
a little compilation of the last couple
days of pramas rallies across the
[Music]
West
am
it's very clear they're saying you in
the west are next tomorrow they're going
to attack Berlin London or Paris don't
stand up and understand that they have a
mission to eliminate us all you don't
really get it wake up and make sure that
you're on the right side of History yeah
yeah you better wake up again there is
some it's not exactly principled as I
said but there there is some I get like
the just I don't want anything to do
with this thing that fight is over there
all of that stuff but they are telling
you what they are coming for and they're
coming for all of our uh freedoms and
our values and our culture and
everything else so we cannot sit idly by
anymore if we do not stand up for what
we believe in right now it will be gone
and if you have kids let's say it is
your duty to hand them a better world
than you were inherited from your
parents do you want to be the person
that says to your kid whoops forgot to
do that I forgot to do that cuz I buried
my head in the sand of course you only
get beheaded a little bit lower on the
next so we better preserve our nation
our family our heritage and our values
or we are in a lot of trouble so now I'd
like to contrast those deeply depressing
rallies where by the way some in some
cases it's not just the Hamas flag it's
the Isis flag and they're calling for
Muslim armies to take over Europe and a
whole bunch more I want to contrast that
to what happened yesterday in Washington
DC and it was rather extraordinary there
was a pro-israel and pro-america rally
in America who knew and yes there were
Israeli Flags but there were just as
many American flags and
290,000 people showed up at the mall in
DC to rally for Israel and for America
and for freedom and Western valys and
all that stuff and former ambassador to
Israel from the UN under Donald Trump
who who was really one of the architects
of the Abraham Accords uh David fredman
he had a great tweet on this he said
290,000 people showing up in DC that is
the largest gathering of Jews since
Mount Si remember Mount Si that's where
Moses came down with the Ten
Commandments you've seen the movie right
anyway here's just a clip of
[Music]
that
that's Atia that's the Israeli National
Anthem and does that feel a little bit
different all of those American flags
nobody was wearing masks dressed like
Cobra soldiers from GI Joe they didn't
burn anything down they cleaned up after
they left they didn't Splash paint all
over the White House or try to scale the
fence or anything like that and yes they
even sang the US national
anthem
[Music]
at the
tlight
lastri and bright
[Music]
St chills I guarantee some of you got
chills watching that because I know that
I did and that is us that is America
that is our
250 plus year history and Heritage of
goodness and decency and watching out
for the minorities and making sure that
there are individual rights and
preserving our Constitution and our Bill
of Rights and that's what that's all
about and I can tell you uh it would be
a beautiful thing if right now in light
of the the absolute medieval Insanity
that we saw on October 7th if it was
those people out there right now that
sparked uh those 300,000 roughly 300,000
people I mean it's an awful lot of
people there are that many Jews in the
world it's only about 15 million Jews
altogether and obviously those all
weren't Jews they were Christians and
I'm sure there were Muslims there and
everything else uh but wouldn't it be
nice if as it felt like we were going
off the cliff going to that endless
abyss and and had Decades of just
sectarian violence in America and just
God only knows what could be on the
other side if we give this thing away
wouldn't it be nice if we grab some of
that feeling right there and and take
that into our lives and figure out a
better way to live and start calling out
the BS artists and the grifters and and
the rest of it before they take power
that's my plan I think it's probably
something you're thinking about too uh
but the point is uh we have to become
one again and I don't mean one meaning
we all have to believe the same things
but we have to start believing that
capitalism is good and worth fighting
for and our founding documents and the
history of America and all of those
things because if that does not happen
we will import leaders who will upend
the entire system so now I want to go
across the globe I want to go to Western
Europe and to Spain uh because something
absolutely extraordinary is happening in
Spain right now there are hundreds of
thousands of Spaniards on the streets
protesting because they want democracy
and they want capitalism and it is uh
they are watching their country being
turned into a socialist nation and they
are not happy about it so thousands and
thousands of people are out there not
burning the city down not ripping up
Spanish Flags very similar to what we
just saw in DC yesterday uh let give you
a little background info from Reuters
here uh tens of thousands of people
protested across Spain on Sunday against
acting prime minister Pedro Sanchez's
plans to Grant amnesty to catalon
separatists in exchange for support for
another term in office the government
secured a deal with catalon separatists
party juns on Thursday which includes
passing a contentious law granting
amnesty to those convicted over
Catalonia's attempt to secede from Spain
in 2017
the deal sent shock waves around the
country with Sanchez's conservative
opponents accusing him of putting the
rule of law on the line for his own
political gain we will not shut up until
there are new elections people party
leader Alberto Nunes vijo told a
cheering crowd packed into Madrid's
puera Delo Square Authority says said
80,000 people turned out in Madrid while
the pp which had called for protests in
cities across Spain put the total closer
to 1 million many held Spanish and EU
flags as well as banners with slogans
including respect the Constitution many
people that I know who vote for the
Socialists feel absolutely disappointed
because Sanchez never said that amnesty
would be part of his program said maala
haran Castro 64 years old so I want to
I'll explain a little bit more about
that because I know that's in the weeds
but let me just show you a bit of the
protests happening in Spain right
[Applause]
now
yeah so thousands and thousands of
people maybe a million people I mean
that is absolutely extraordinary and
they are pro Spain they are pro
democracy and they are against making
deals with socialists to upend their
society let me just say I'm not going to
sit here and tell you that I'm an
absolute expert in Spanish politics so
we will bring on some people to talk
about it at a more in-depth level but I
am telling you this is one of these
markers that you see every now and again
where you see something happening in
another country and you go something is
happening there that is important
another way you might know that it's
important is that Tucker Carlson is in
Spain right now out there protesting
with the people trying to save their
country check this out anybody who would
violate your Constitution potentially
use physical violence to end democracy
is a is a tyrant is a dictator and this
is happening in the middle of Europe so
we thought it deserved more coverage
than it's getting
with this
if your government is
allowing foreigners to come in and hurt
you they're committing war against you
you know our news media doesn't report a
lot of things and in our time here it's
very obvious that the Socialists in an
alliance with a separatist are trying to
end the rule of law in Spain if you
don't have freedom of speech you don't
have the freedom to defend yourself and
you can't vote your way out of it the
system is rigged you're in real trouble
real trouble so I I'm really rooting for
your success is the world actually
seeing how um important is what is
happening here no no the world is not
seeing how important it is um but we
hope to change that yeah I'm sure you
will thank you very much than you we
hope to change that indeed and Tucker
Carlson is doing the right thing again I
I'm not an expert in every little bit of
what is happening on the ground there uh
but does the idea of the elites flooding
your country with people who shouldn't
be there and growing signs of socialism
and stamping down on descent and all of
that that kind of stuff that sound like
maybe kind of a little bit of what's
going on here too so you might want to
care what's happening in Spain right
that's why these things you don't have
to care about the Jews particularly but
you might want to care about what's
happening to Israel a western democracy
in a place where there isn't a lot of
that you may not care about the Spanish
people specifically or you might not
care about Western Europe but you might
go oh there's something happening there
that could kind of happen here and of
course because of the internet and
because of phones our connectivity and
the ability for these riots whether
they're riots to tear down Societies or
whether they're protests to uphold the
goodness of society they can spread like
wildfire so this is what's happening in
America right now we have a political
party and and by the way the Republicans
kind of suck too right but we have a
political party of the Democrats that
are trying to flood America with
non-westerners who will vote for
Democrats and then eventually they will
have the house they will have the Senate
they will have the White House and what
will they do but you know what it's not
just them because yes I often say I am a
Florida Republican very proudly first
time I ever registered as a republican
here in Florida but the national
Republican project I don't know what to
make of it I really do not know what to
make of it so now I want to jump uh from
that back to the States and to what's
going on with some of our presidential
candidates right now because Nikki Haley
and I consider myself friendly with
Nikki Haley she's had dinner at my house
she is a fine a fine lady I obviously do
not agree with her on everything uh she
said something that was that was pretty
scary a couple days ago on the ruthless
podcast uh she went on there uh and she
you'll see she's now I think we're
showing you a Fox news clip if I'm not
mistaken right it's from Fox News she
followed up on the notion that she
brought up on the ruthless podcast about
how she wants to require every person on
social media to be verified by ID
meaning no Anonymous accounts on social
media uh here she is when I get into
office the first thing we have to do
social media accounts social media
companies they have to show America
their algorithms let us see why they're
pushing what they're pushing the second
thing is every person on social media
should be verified by their name that's
first of all it's a national security
threat when you do that all of a sudden
people have to stand by what they say
and it gets rid of the Russian Bots the
Iranian Bots and the Chinese Bots and
then you're going to get some civility
when people know their name is next to
what they say accountability and they
know their pastor and their family
members going to see it it's going to
help our kids and it's going to help our
country okay so there there's a couple
things here first off the the first
concept that she said which is that I
would go into the social media companies
and make them show their algorithms
we've discussed this before it is
unclear if the social media companies
know what's going on in their algorithms
Al together as Elon Musk literally told
me personally the the Twitter code is a
fractal rubbe Goldberg machine remember
rub Goldberg machine the beginning of
PeeWee Herman's Big Adventure the ball
that drops into the thing and it fills
up up the water and it knocks Down The
Dominoes and everything else and a
fractal version of that meaning it is so
layered it is so confused it's been
written 20 years ago by many people who
are no longer at the company and by the
way this goes for Google this goes for
Facebook this goes for YouTube and
everywhere else that the idea that the
that government agents could walk in to
Google or Twitter or elsewhere and be
like show us the algorithm like some
middle management pathetic government
employee with a hard hat could I want to
see the algorithm and I'm going to
figure it out like the very notion of
that is is sort of completely ridiculous
the the concept like intellectually
would it be nice if we knew what the
algorithms were saying and which way
they were pushing you if you happen to
watch a Reuben report video and I say
something that might let's say push you
this way a little bit is the YouTube
algorithm trying to counter that with a
whole bunch of other things because they
don't want you to think things that I
think so the concept in Theory actually
makes some sense that we should know
about the algorithms uh but in terms of
what the government can do and how the
government might use that against you
ultimately I think you see my point now
on the on the more sort of uh let's say
scary side of this thing uh she's saying
that Anonymous accounts online are a
national security threat and she's
talking about these Russian and Iranian
Bots and all that first off there's
there's two different things happening
here on one hand the ability for people
to be anonymous online look I find it to
be a massive headache all the time right
because the people that write the worst
things to me all day long all day long
and I assure you in the last month it's
been worse than ever they're always
Anonymous that's like that's how it is
and you have no idea which ones of them
are Bots and and now with AI they can
the Bots can be really clever and really
come across like their people but the
idea that people should be allowed to be
anonymous you know the Federalist Papers
were written by Anonymous founders of
this country uh because they did not
want to get in trouble with the King
over in Britain you know so there is
obviously a reason that people should be
able to have anonymity as annoying as it
is now if she wanted to figure out a way
to encourage let's say the big tech
companies to go after the Bots yes the
Bots are a huge problem because what's
happening is we're seeing people be
swarmed so that you cannot gauge what's
true so if you were to just say
something something completely um
completely ambivalent right water is wet
you will get a jillion bots in your
account you think you're a racist
because you think water's wet what about
vapor
and and they look like real people and
it can actually
disregulated all that and we know
obviously a huge amount is coming out of
Russia and China and Iran and everywhere
else but the idea that you would take
away anonymity altogether is nuts I
would say one other thing on this and
then I'll move on when we created locals
and we were trying to figure out well
how do we deal with all the haters
because so much of the internet is
filled with hate my general premise was
if we just charge a couple bucks a month
to people that will that will basically
clean up all of the bad behavior and if
it doesn't if someone comes in my locals
Community to constantly tell me I'm evil
or I'm an or everyone else here
is horrible or a racist then I can kick
them out of my locals Community the way
I wouldn't invite someone into my home
to call me all of those things but if
you want to call me all those things
from the Public Square from the local
park you can still do that so you could
still be in someone else's local
community so anyway I mentioned that not
even to promote locals as much to just
say there are mature ways to think about
these things the idea that we would just
give the power to the government uh to
surveil us and tell us what we can say
and when we can say it uh especially a
couple years out of coid that seems like
a problem uh speaking of coid and crazy
people and surveillance and everything
else Kathy hokel who is the uh well we
call her Kathy seaward here she is uh
the governor of New York uh she's very
excited because she's going to be
conducting surveillance on social media
to combat speech also we're very focused
on the data we're collecting from
surveillance efforts what's being set on
social media platforms and we have
launched an effort to be able to counter
some of the negativity and reach out to
people when we see hate speech being
spoken about on on online plat uh Kathy
that's against the Constitution if
someone is making a direct threat if
they are saying they're going to come
kill someone we already have laws around
them
uh there is no such thing as hate speech
the Supreme Court has already ruled on
that one person's hate speech is another
person's Free Speech all of you guys
understand all that but now she is using
the government of New York to surveil
what people say online and of course
this shouldn't surprise us because we
now know through the Twitter files and
everything else and through government
hearings and what Jim Jordan released uh
you know a week and a half ago or so uh
that this is what the government has
been doing and the real question is can
they just keep doing it because we don't
seem to to get rid of these people they
keep coming back and then the Democrats
keep electing them over and over and
over Kathy hokel just won an election in
New York uh but I want to connect this
quickly just jump back to the coid times
because there is a connection between
the people who will gladly try to stop
you from speaking right now and the very
same people who are trying to lock you
down inject you with stuff and tell you
what you had to wear on your face just
two years ago I today am announcing that
we are enacting a Statewide indoor mask
mandate unless a business has a
vaccination mandate yeah and it turned
out that the vaccine did not protect you
from coid nor stop you from spreading
coid and everything else on top of the
fact that they had no right to do that
in the first place and we have the right
to assemble and you have the right to
make medical decisions for yourself and
everything else so what is the point of
all of this how do we bring this all
back to where we started in that uh
interview with the oon and with Dana
White well the way you put this all
together is that it is your chance right
now again it's it's just getting shorter
Can You Feel The End of the Road getting
a little bit closer if we don't do
something soon uh it is your chance
right now to put your family your
country and your values above all else
no matter how choppy the water is no
matter what they're saying about you
you're a Nazi you're a
bigot because they are going to keep
coming so now I want to jump back to
that interview that we started with Dana
White and the o on check this out right
in Co they're laying people off and
whatever we didn't lay anybody
off didn't you didn't you negate some of
your salary or something what you guys
do no I said I would but okay I said
we're going to go through this we're not
laying anybody off we're going through
this and
um you know every Christmas party I get
up on stage and tell my team how
much I love them and how important they
are to me and then the scariest Time In
Our Lifetime uh hits and I'm like hey
yeah I love you guys so much I'm going
to lay off some of you have been
with me 10 15 20 years the I'm one of
these guys the whole ship goes
down together or not at all we're all
sinking me included or we don't
at all you know and and uh you know that
doesn't exist in in this world that we
live in today everybody's just so easy
to pull the trigger and let go of some
of their people and no it's something
good I need to hear that you know I'm
not a UFC guy like it's not something I
really care about that much I know
millions and millions of people do but I
love people that stand up for what's
right I also want to add that I and the
two businesses that I was running during
Co did not fire anybody we actually
hired a couple people we facilitated
people being able to work from home um
and and on the locals front we had a
bunch of just to connect this to
something else we had a bunch of
programmers in Ukraine who we helped
facilitate get to another country uh so
that they could move their families and
be out of Harm's Way like there are ways
that you can do something to help people
and not to abandon all of your
principles and everything else and if we
all start doing that
really if we all start doing that just
whatever that means to you in your life
then you might be able to extrapolate
that to a wider Community build up that
way so now remember where we started we
started with Dana uh asking Theo well
who was The Advertiser that said uh that
if you put the RFK interview up we're
not going to advertise you advertise you
advertise with you anymore well Theo
actually did remember and I'm pretty
sure you've heard of this company and
I'm pretty sure you should not buy their
products anymore go pelaton was the we
just got an update um P was the B was
the people who wanted an ad out pelaton
and meanwhile you have RFK so pelaton
yeah what do they sell bik the
stationary bikes yeah dude pelons sell
stationary bikes and they got a problem
with Robert
Kennedy you pelaton what who the
are they yeah first right are you
kidding me yeah yeah
pelaton calling bitching about Robert
Kennedy yeah dude you want to go nowhere
who who's the CEO of pelaton do we have
pelons in the gym are those
pelaton asport no no there's bikes next
to it asort as yeah we're getting rid of
them yeah all right first off I did not
know that the F in Robert F Kennedy
standed for yeah but uh again Conor
completely lost control and we didn't
blur any of that beep any of that I'm
sorry about that really I'm trying to
control the F bombs and a lot know a lot
of you love it when I curse and it's
like this like release of steam and
everything else but I know a lot of you
are also watching this there might be
kids in the room and everything so we
will try to control that a bit more we
just L control it was a lot it was a lot
you know you can only press that button
so many times before you start losing
your mind anyway you got the point what
Dana White is doing there fighting
against these advertisers saying I'm
going to get rid of my pelaton bikes
right now like that's what he said and
Theo van calling out the advertisers for
doing that and then people that will go
ahead and build new things and UFC
making a deal with Rumble all of the
stuff guys that is the chance but the
chance also is when there is a rally in
your town that is a rally that is pro
Amer Pro the values you care about maybe
show up uh you know there's a um a diner
in a town in Long Island I think it's in
Huntington a diner owned by a Greek guy
and he put up all of the posters of the
missing people in Israel and then he was
getting boycotted and there happens to
be a lot of a lot of Jews in Long Island
they have been showing up in droves in
droves I'm going to try to get the guy
on the show I saw an interview with him
really nice guy and it turns out he went
to my high school by total coincidence
he's a couple years older than me uh but
like he did something that he felt was
important he got pushed back from a
certain set of crazy people and then
good people started showing up and
eating at his Diner and that's what we
can do to save each other we can stand
up for what we believe we can put our
dollars where our values are and maybe
we'll turn this thing around that is the
mission I Leave You now but I will be
back with people of the internet at 1
pm. with my co-host Isabelle Brown my
full interview from Arc in London with
Dennis Prager is up across platforms
right now and oh and by the way if you
have not followed us yet I don't know
that I've mentioned it on this show
specifically we have a new Twitter
account that's going to be just for
clips of the show so I'm my Twitter
account is going to be more of my
personal thoughts and then we're going
to promo Ruben report stuff it is at
Ruben report show Ruben report show on X
Twitter whatever the high hell you call
it I thank you for watching and we leave
you with a cold clothes of the elderly
man pretending to be president goodbye
that under bomic she won't have to leave
home now to get a good job I don't know
how many times I've heard and out on the
road people saying my kid came up to me
and said he wanted to live in my
basement and play Xbox all day well in
her biomics we made that happen I know
all about staying in the basement I ran
a whole campaign for my
[Music]
basement